describe 5 55 55 55 como una expresión
de multiplicación escribe la expresión
tres veces utilizando distintas formas
de escribir la multiplicación vamos a
hacer algo primero vamos a contar
cuántas veces tenemos ese número 5 y
veamos la tenemos una dos tres cuatro
cinco seis siete veces esto no podemos
pensar como que tengo el número cinco
siete veces
el número 5 lo tengo 7 veces
o también podemos decir que tenemos el
número 5
que se está sumando a sí mismo siete
veces vamos a poner el 5
sumado
multiplicado
siete veces
ok esto es importante está sumándose a
sí mismo siete veces lo que también
podemos decir que se está multiplicando
por siete veces vamos a ponerlo de
diferentes maneras porque esto
simplemente es como lo estamos viendo
aún no hemos hecho la parte matemática
vamos a escribirlo de este lado si tengo
el 5 x 7 veces también lo puedo
representar como el 5
multiplicado este puntito significa que
se está multiplicando por 7
tenemos el símbolo de multiplicación que
conocemos o también les presento uno
nuevo que es este punto incluso hay otra
forma pero lo colocaremos acá abajo se
han puesto a pensar qué pasa si ponemos
que son siete veces el 5 ustedes pueden
alternar la posición de estas constantes
dentro de la multiplicación y tendremos
que 5 por 7 es lo mismo que 7 por 5 así
es que colocaremos aquí también 7 por 5
con el punto que les acabo de mostrar y
ahora tienen también una nueva forma que
les parece si lo ponemos por paréntesis
si tengo un 5
en un paréntesis y un 7 en otro esto
significa también una multiplicación
vamos a poner el 7 que está
multiplicando al 5 simplemente estamos
alternando la posición de las constantes
ok y esto todo esto todo esto todo esto
ya que lo hemos trabajado tanto vamos a
hacer la multiplicación si tú tienes 5
por 7 nuestro resultado será
y voy a colocarlo en todos y cada uno de
estos espacios para que ustedes se den
cuenta que estamos hablando de lo mismo
7 x 5 es igual a 35 ya se aprendieron
sus tablas de multiplicar 5 por 7 es lo
mismo que aquí y estamos hablando de 35
de la misma manera que 7 por 5 es igual
a 35
7 x 5 es igual a 35 recuerda que los
paréntesis funcionan de la misma manera
mostrando una multiplicación y 5 por 7
es igual a 35
de esta manera tenemos la expresión de
distintas formas y hemos visto que
tenemos el 5 o 7 veces pero también nos
hemos dado cuenta que es exactamente lo
mismo si decimos que tenemos el número 7
cinco veces
y eso lo voy a colocar aquí digo no no
los están pidiendo arriba pero lo
colocaré para que ustedes tengan el
razonamiento tenemos el 7 una vez dos
veces tres veces cuatro veces cinco
veces como vamos a comprobar que este 35
es lo mismo
que esté 35 pues muy fácil 55 10 515 520
más 5 25 si le sumamos a 25 5 tenemos 30
y si sumamos estos últimos 5 tenemos 35
qué es exactamente este 35 que hemos
colocado aquí lo notan ahora hagamos la
suma de los sietes 77 es igual a 14 14
más 7 es igual a 21 21 más 7 es igual a
28 28 7 es igual a 35 y de esta manera
tendremos que 5 por 7 es igual a 35 de
la misma manera que 7 por 5 es igual a
35 y con esto tenemos nuestra respuesta
correcta
nos vemos en otro vídeo más adelante